women in combat is a national Scandal it
is a disgrace it is a deep deep shame
and stain on our country
and I don't even hear the conservative
politicians talking about this women in
combat is a very recent phenomenon and
yet we just totally gave up that fight
why because we don't want to be seen as
disrespecting women who serve in the
military I have the utmost respect for
women who serve in the military I'm
deeply grateful for their inclination to
serve and sacrifice the military is not
about individual desires it's not even
about individual ability
it's about cohesion and unity and
National policy and who we want to be as
a nation I have no doubt that's that
there are a significant number of women
who would valiantly go out and risk
their lives and bodily Integrity To Go
Fight For America I don't want them to
do that
I think it's bad for America to send
women into Harm's Way